para ser totalmente honesto contigo no
pasó mucho tiempo pensando en mis
funciones corporales al menos no todo el
tiempo pero en los próximos episodios
hablaré sobre todos los sistemas que
hacen que nuestras vidas sean posibles
incluso ocasionalmente placenteras y
para comenzar hoy directamente al
control de la misión el sistema nervioso
casi todos los animales excepto algunos
muy simples tienen sistemas nerviosos lo
cual es genial porque es lo que permite
a los seres vivos tener comportamientos
se convierte en el ser vivo consciente
que eres todo el conjunto de tu cerebro
tus nervios tu médula espinal todo está
formado por células especializadas que
no se encuentran en ningún otro lugar
del cuerpo la mayoría de estas son
neuronas que las has visto antes se ven
como un árbol con raíces tronco y ramas
las neuronas se agrupan para formar
nervios vías que transmiten señales
electroquímicas de una parte de tu
cuerpo a otra y entonces cuando muerdes
un trozo de pizza me encanta cuando hay
picks en los vídeos los receptores
neuronales alrededor de mis papilas
gustativas reconocen que estoy comiendo
algo salado graso e increíble y llevan
esa información a lo largo de un camino
nervioso hasta mi cerebro y entonces mi
cerebro dice si pizzas y luego responde
enviando información a través de
diferentes vías nerviosas que dicen que
debería comer más de esa pizza y sin
embargo a pesar de lo que mi cerebro
dice
no comer más de esta pizza no pensarías
que es terriblemente complicado saber
que la pizza sabe bien y decirle a
alguien que coma más pizza pero resulta
que nuestros cerebros y nuestro sistema
nervioso son muy complicados el sistema
nervioso básicamente es una gran
burocracia de neuronas y está dividido
en dos departamentos principales el
sistema nervioso central y el sistema
nervioso periférico central y periférico
por el sistema nervioso central
básicamente tu cerebro y la médula
espinal es responsable de analizar e
interpretar todos los datos que el
sistema nervioso periférico todos los
nervios fuera del cerebro y la columna
vertebral recolecta y envía una vez que
el sistema nervioso central toma una
decisión sobre estos datos envía una
señal de regreso al sistema nervioso
periférico indicando lo que debe hacer
el sistema nervioso periférico y que
éste hace estos sistemas también
contienen dos tipos diferentes de
neuronas aferentes diferentes oferentes
diferentes son términos biológicos
terriblemente confusos y pido disculpas
en nombre de toda la institución de
biología por ellos los sistemas a
gerentes llevan las cosas a un punto
central y existe
más diferentes llevan las cosas lejos
del punto central entonces las neuronas
aferentes transportan información al
cerebro y la médula espinal para su
análisis y las neuronas referentes del
sistema nervioso periférico se denominan
neuronas sensoriales y se activan con
estímulos externos como el glorioso y
complejo sabor de la pizza y luego
convierten esos datos en una señal para
que la procese del sistema nervioso
central el sistema nervioso central
también tiene neuronas a gerentes que
llevan información a partes especiales
del cerebro
como la parte del cerebro que dice
salado las neuronas diferentes llevan
información fuera del centro y en el
sistema nervioso periférico se llaman
neuronas motoras porque muchas de ellas
llevan información desde el cerebro a la
médula espinal a los músculos para
hacernos mover pero también van a casi
todos los demás órganos de tu cuerpo
para hacerlos trabajar y hacer cosas
para mantenerte con vida y en el sistema
nervioso central las neuronas gerentes
transportan información desde partes
especiales del cuerpo a otras partes del
cuerpo o la médula espinal por supuesto
si esto fuera todo sería demasiado
simple y ninguna buena burocracia
solo dos departamentos por lo que el
sistema nervioso periférico en realidad
se compone de dos sistemas diferentes
con dos trabajos muy diferentes el
sistema nervioso somático y el sistema
nervioso autónomo el sistema somático
controla todas las cosas que piensas
hacer como toda la información que llega
a través de tus sentidos y al movimiento
del cuerpo cuando quieres moverlo dado
que estamos totalmente enamorados de
nuestros cerebros como una especie de
centro de todo nuestro ser creemos que
toda la información de lo que sucede en
nuestro cuerpo va a nuestro cerebro para
tomar algún tipo de decisión pero no es
así a veces como cuando tocamos una
estufa caliente las neuronas aferentes
llevan la señal de caliente al sistema
nervioso central pero esa información ni
siquiera llega al cerebro la médula
espinal en realidad toma esa decisión
antes de llegar al cerebro y envía el
mensaje directamente de regreso a los
músculos diciendo aquí está la mano de
la estufa este pequeño y sofisticado
trabajo de nervios permite que la médula
espinal tome decisiones en lugar del
cerebro y se llama arco reflejo la otra
rama del sistema nervioso periférico el
sistema autónomo transmite señales del
sistema nervioso central que impulsan
todas las cosas que hace tu cuerpo sin
pensar
y tus latidos cardíacos o digestión
respiración producción de saliva todas
las funciones orgánicas pero aún no
terminamos aquí necesitamos ir más
profundo el sistema nervioso autónomo
tiene dos decisiones propias la
simpática y la parasimpático y los
trabajos que realizan estos dos no son
sólo diferentes son completamente
opuestos y francamente siempre están
compitiendo por el control del cuerpo en
algún tipo de lucha en jaula del sistema
nervioso la división simpática es
responsable de cómo enloquecer o
probablemente hayas escuchado hablar de
esto como la respuesta de luchar o huir
en otras palabras estrés pero el estrés
no es todo malo es lo que salva nuestras
vidas cuando nos persiguen tigres
dientes de sable verdad el sistema
simpático prepara nuestro cuerpo para la
acción al aumentar la frecuencia
cardíaca y la presión arterial mejora
nuestro sentido del olfato dilata las
pupilas activa nuestra corteza
suprarrenal para hacer adrenalina sirve
el suministro de sangre al sistema
digestivo y reproductivo para que haya
más sangre disponible para los pulmones
y músculos cuando tenemos que correr y
aunque no estés en un estado constante
de pánico al menos espero que no yo
y ese sistema está funcionando todo el
tiempo todos los días pero justo al lado
está la de nación para simpática que
trabaja arduamente para asegurarse de
que te relajes y te lo tomes con calma
reduce el ritmo cardíaco y la presión
arterial contra de los pulmones hace que
nuestra nariz bote aumenta el flujo de
sangre a nuestra región reproductiva
hace que la boca produzca saliva nos
anima a defecar y orinar es básicamente
al que tenemos que agradecer por tomar
una siesta sentarnos frente al televisor
o ir al baño y hacer lo que tenemos que
hacer así que considera te afortunado de
tener la respuesta al estrés y la
respuesta relajada trabajando lado a
lado porque juntas crean un equilibrio
homeostasis ahora eso es lo que hace el
sistema nervioso después tenemos que
hablar sobre cómo lo hace las neuronas
que componen nuestro sistema nervioso
hacen posible que nuestros cuerpos
tengan sus propios pequeños sistemas
electrónicos para entender cómo
funcionan debes comprender su anatomía
como dije antes la neurona típica tiene
ramas como un árbol estas se llaman
dendritas y reciben información de otras
neuronas las neuronas también tienen un
axón único el tronco del árbol
al final y transmite señales a otras
neuronas el acción también está cubierto
de un material graso llamado mielina que
actúa como aislante
pero la cubierta de mielina no es
continua hay máquinas secciones de
neurona expuesta a lo largo del axón que
se llaman nodos de ramier se parece un
excelente título para la última novela
de harry potter harry potter y los nodos
de rangers en fin estos nodos permiten
que las señales salten de un nodo a otro
lo que hace que la señal viaje por el
nervio más rápido por cierto este salto
de nodos tiene un nombre se llama
conducción salta toria en conducción
porque es una conducción eléctrica y
salta toria porque salta finalmente el
lugar donde las ramas de un axón entran
en contacto con la dendrita de la
siguiente célula se llama sinapsis y es
ahí donde los neurotransmisores
transmiten información de una neurona a
la siguiente ahora recuerda o
simplemente mira el episodio que hicimos
sobre las membranas celulares donde
hablábamos sobre como los materiales
viajan por gradientes de concentración
bueno todas las neuronas en tu cuerpo
tienen un potencial de membrana una
diferencia de voltaje o carga eléctrica
entre el interior y el exterior de la
membrana también puede
recordar que esta acumulación de
voltajes se maneja en parte por una
pequeña proteína sexy llamada bomba de
sodio potasio básicamente la goma crea
un diferencial de voltaje como cargar
una batería al sacar presiones de sodio
positivos por cada dos iones de potasio
que entran lo que permite crear una
carga negativa neta dentro de la célula
en relación con el exterior cuando una
neurona está inactiva se llama potencial
de reposo y el voltaje es de
aproximadamente menos 70 milivoltios
pero además de las bombas las neuronas
también tienen canales iónicos estos son
proteínas que se extienden por la
membrana pero son mucho más simples y no
necesitan atp para energizar las cada
célula podría tener más de 300 tipos
diferentes de canales iónicos cada uno
adaptado para aceptar un ión específico
ahora no tienes con la inversa tivo
porque todo esto entrará en juego cuando
una neurona se active esto sucede cuando
un estímulo crea un cambio en la neurona
que finalmente alcanza el axón creando
lo que se llama un potencial de acción
un breve evento donde el potencial
eléctrico de la célula aumenta y
disminuye rápidamente cuando comienza un
potencial de acción como cuando una
molécula
azúcar toca una de mis papilas
gustativas dulces algunos canales de
iones se abren y dejan que esos iones de
sodio positivos se precipiten al
interior de manera que comience a ser
menos negativo con un estímulo apagado
el tracto interno de la neurona alcanza
un cierto umbral que desencadena la
respuesta de más canales de sodio que
abran las compuertas y dejen entrar aún
más iones eso está sucediendo en una
pequeña área de la neurona pero este
cambio en el voltaje se arrastra al
siguiente grupo de canales de sodio que
también son sensibles al voltaje y por
lo tanto se abren ese intercambio
desencadena el siguiente lote y el
siguiente lote y así sucesivamente ese
entonces el voltaje de cambio de señal
viaja por la membrana de la neurona como
una onda pero recuerda que la cobertura
de mielina aísla la mayor parte de la
neurona y simplemente deja esos pequeños
nodos expuestos entonces en lugar de ser
una onda constante la onda salta de nodo
a nodo acelerando el tiempo de viaje del
potencial de acción por una neurona así
funciona la conducción salta toria
cuando la ola llega al final de la
neurona y desencadena una liberación de
neurotransmisores desde la neurona a
través del éxtasis esos
neurotransmisores fluyen
de la sinapsis a la siguiente neurona
donde desencadenan otro potencial de
acción allí en este momento ya han
entrado tantos iones de sodio en la
primera neurona que la diferencia entre
el exterior y el interior se invierte el
interior es positivo y el exterior es
negativo y parece que las neuronas odian
eso más que nada porque lo arreglan
solas los canales de sodio se cierran y
los canales de potasio se abren los
iones de potasio positivos se precipitan
tanto en la concentración como en los
gradientes electroquímicos para salir
rápidamente de la célula eso hace que la
carga dentro de la célula vuelva a ser
negativa en el interior y positiva en el
exterior ten en cuenta que ahora el
sodio está en el interior de la célula y
el potasio está en el exterior en los
lugares opuestos de donde comenzaron por
lo que vuelve al trabajo la bomba sodio
potasio quema algo de atp para bombear
el sodio afuera y el potasio adentro y
vayan las cosas ahora vuelven al
potencial de descanso nuevamente y es
así amigos como el potencial de acción
permite que las neuronas comuniquen
señales a través de una cadena completa
de neuronas desde los confines del
sistema nervioso periférico hasta la
médula espinal y el cerebro
y luego vuelven a salir así que veamos
la imagen completa voy a morder esta
pizza todas mis papilas gustativas
tienen neuronas en ellas cada una de mis
papilas gustativas contiene entre 50 y
100 neuronas receptoras del punto
especializadas los productos químicos de
esta hermosa pizza se disuelven en
saliva y luego estimulan las dendritas
en la neurona a frente esto genera un
montón de potenciales de acción que
viajan desde las neuronas a gerentes en
mi lengua hasta mi cerebro que dice ay
caray
creo que es pizza darle otra mordida
luego el cerebro envía mensajes a través
de las vías nerviosas a gerentes para
hacer todo tipo de cosas primero
masticar que consiste en contraer los
músculos de mi mandíbula una y otra vez
y dos bajar la cabeza para dar otra
mordida que involucra otro tipo de
músculos del cuello 3 para dar lo que
implica contraer los músculos de la
garganta y el esófago 4 abrir mi boca
nuevamente para obtener otro bocado esta
señal también va a mi mandíbula y ni
siquiera mencionamos qué sucederá con la
digestión de este chico malo impulsado
por el sistema nervioso autónomo
pero la dirección la veremos en un
capítulo futuro en donde con suerte
habrá más pizza